because if you don't get fed that you
don't find out about julian assange
getting kicked out of the embassy in
london you don't find out about a
million different stories that are in
the news it's a fun story it's a cool
story but do I need to know it that's a
quote for you from now on
hey what about Julian Assange Tom Papa
hands up in clothes it's a fun story
it's a fun story but I don't need to
know it really you just redefined white
privilege seriously what can I do about
a lot of these you know look I think
it's good that information is flowing
and that moves everybody forward but you
know for me sitting in there trying to
tell some jokes and feed my kids it's
like do I need to know everything every
trouble spot going around the world oh
it's like that is very good question
it's like how much responsibility do you
have to be tuned in to all the events of
the world and to act look how much
responsibility do you have outside of
voting and do you have the
responsibility to vote because there's
some people that are very interesting
people that don't vote yeah you know I
don't agree with that yeah it's a what
participate I understand that but I
don't think Michael MAOIs votes doesn't
he does didn't he say he doesn't vote I
think he said he doesn't
I forget his reasoning but it was very
logical uh-huh no I understand the
argument but I even even if it seems
kind of false and I just I think it kind
of like mentally engages you in the
world yeah you you should be trying to
participate I think his perspective is
that as a commentator on the world
that'd be better off if he didn't
actually vote mm-hmm and just look at it
how he really sees it on both sides
right if I'm just a partial yeah I'm
sure I'm butchering the way he would
phrase it right I think it's a lot in
the spirit of that yeah if you vote you
don't have a right to complain that was
deep but I think but look it's it's a
lot look I think
it's trying to be a good person I'm just
a person level and trying to take care
of your family and work hard and be good
with people and help your community
that's kind of the extent of what you
can do and hopefully that spreads out
but you know right Julian Assange okay
really I mean why is that
you know well like all those people that
were talking about at that generation
that only got news during that six
o'clock hour mm-hmm
you know were they less citizens of the
world because they only got that little
dose I don't know they were less
informed and the idea is that more
people can get away with things they
shouldn't be able to get away with like
what's happening right now with Julian
Assange Julian Assange in anybody's
estimation if you look at what he did he
distributed information that was
extremely interesting to most people in
the world that didn't know about it
right he exposed a lot of scary shit
yeah he supposed a lot of corruption
supposed a lot of I mean what what
corruption did it expose I know it
exposed there was that was a Collateral
Murder video that was the one of the
first ones I they showed them shooting
they shot at these guys where they
thought were soldiers and they were they
were reporters and it was sort of just
the way they dealt with it it was very
scary for people watching that someone
could just like dehumanize accidentally
killing the wrong people and right I
make it like that was the military they
were making it like you know hey but you
kind of have to be in that mindset to be
able to gun people down from the sky in
the first place you know look you gotta
put yourself in the perspective of
someone who has to do that job yeah and
you take a regular person and then you
train them to do that job and then you
ask them to go and pull the trigger
people they're gonna develop a coldness
to them people you know that cut they
have to yeah right but to see it so mm
what Julian Assange did is he showed it
to us and then he released all sorts of
I mean I haven't I'm embarrassed to say
that I haven't really studied all the
files and what was released and what
wasn't apparently was the no and Ben
Shapiro was here he said that people's
names got put out and apparently that
was someone hacked
into WikiLeaks and release that
information before they could redact the
names this was the this is what I've
been told by multiple sources so in it
but again I didn't look into it I don't
know if that was correct so they're
gonna say that he was treasonous or that
he was I don't know what they're gonna
say I think that you're the first thing
was a sex charge that's what they were
trying to say that he had sex with a
woman they where he wore a condom and
then they had sex and then they had sex
in the morning with no condom she didn't
consent to that that he just kind of did
it or something I think it was something
long I think they called it surprise sex
uh-huh and if I'm butchering this I'm
sorry but the that didn't make sense
like that there would be going after him
that way well you know obviously not
about that yeah you go after if you want
to get somebody you go after or whatever
I think there's yeah I'm like hacking
charges now right yeah I don't know I
know a little crazy in the in the
embassy right he wouldn't clean up after
his cat and he was on a scooter around
is that true that's what I don't know
who knows what's true no that's probably
but that's was part of the little story
that I caught the little done it was
done she was poetically describing what
the embassy must smelled like with
Julian's dirty cat shit wafting through
the halls crazy asshole you have staying
here won't leave Pamela Anderson comes
over every now and then they get their
freak on surveillance footage of Julian
Assange skateboarding and the Ecuadorian
Embassy in London has been leaked kinda
okay
yeah but here's the thing man like what
do you want the guy to do is there a
problem he's there for seven fucking
years now he must have gone crazy yeah I
mean that's like being you know under
house arrest dude I mean it's amazing
that he lasted that long what they did
they waited him out and then when it
they were never gonna wait him out he
was gonna stay in there forever
and then I guys got sick of him they
just got sick of him I think it was also
of the Ecuadorian president I think he
took a photograph in front of like some
lobsters and shit and it was from a
leaked email and that photo got out and
it was very embarrassing to him because
his country's in a deep financial crisis
oh and he's chilling in some Four
Seasons somewhere
he loves turning Steger